Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, j'ai reçu une question qui me tient énormément à coeur de la part d'Anne-Marie.
Elle me demande : « Peux-tu expliquer la crise qui
secoue présentement Kanesatake et Oka? »
Anne-Marie, pour pouvoir même commencer
à l'expliquer, je vais remonter en 1990,
parce qu'on parle d'un événement
historique au Québec, c'est-à-dire
la crise d'Oka, ce que les militants
autochtones préfèrent appeler
la résistance d'Oka, parce que c'est un
moment où justement la communauté
de Kahnawake a défendu les droits pour un
territoire qu'elle considère non-cédé.
C'est-à-dire, la pinède d'Oka qui devait
être transformée en terrain de golf.
On sait que pendant l'été de 1990, il y a
eu une présence militaire sur ce terrain-là
pour pouvoir contrer justement les
réclamations des Mohawks de Kanesatake.
Presque 30 ans plus tard, on
revient : mêmes enjeux, même pinède,
même nation – encore à Kanesatake –, un
nouveau maire, cependant, et présentement
on vit un moment politique qui est très
mélangeant, parce que beaucoup de ces
enjeux-là ne sont pas connus.
Premièrement, le transfert de terrains
qui doivent se faire donner maintenant
à Kanesatake vient d'un développeur qui a
des terrains un peu partout autour d'Oka.
Il veut redonner la pinède
à la communauté. Certains membres de la
communauté sont très contents
de recevoir le terrain. Ils disent que c'est une des
premières avancées qu'il y a, enfin,
par rapport aux réclamations
qu'on a sur la pinède.
Mais il y a aussi une partie de la communauté
qui ne sont pas d'accord parce que
justement, ces terrains n'ont jamais
été cédés. En recevant les terrains
du promoteur ce serait comme dire
« finalement ils appartenaient à cette
personne et elle nous les donne », alors que
pour une question de réclamer de futurs
et de présent droits ancestraux, ces
terrains-là doivent être reconnus comme
n'avoir jamais été cédés. Donc, il y a une
question importante par rapport à
est-ce qu'on reçoit un cheval de Troie
présentement en se faisant donner un
terrain et que présentement la Cour
suprême canadienne après va dire
« vous recevez des terrains des promoteurs,
donc vous reconnaissez que c'est
des transferts de terrain
plus traditionnels non autochtones
que liés aux droits ancestraux autochtones ».
Ça c'est le premier
angle qu'on peut voir et là,
malheureusement, c'est perdu un peu dans
le message, parce qu'il y a eu des propos
très malheureux et très disgracieux de
la part du maire qui ont mis de
l'essence dans le feu, comme on dit.
Et ce qu'on voit beaucoup présentement
dans les médias, aussi, c'est qu'il y a eu
des interactions entre certains journalistes
et des membres de la communauté
de Kanesatake. Et ce deuxième angle est
aussi un peu perdu dans la compréhension
de la population, parce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier qu'en 1990, les membres
de la communauté étaient présents et ont subi
quand même une couverture médiatique
qui était très dommageable pour la
communauté et qui, encore aujourd'hui,
a des impacts. Donc, de voir des médias arriver et de se demander est-ce qu'ils
vont encore nous couvrir de la même
manière qu'en 1990, parce qu'ils arrivent
seulement quand il y a une crise,
c'est de ne pas douter de voir des réactions
très vives de la part des membres
de la communauté. Par chance, aujourd'hui, il y a eu
un travail de transformation des médias et
aussi, on peut compter sur des médias
autochtones comme APTN,
qui est apparu en 1992 après la crise d'Oka,
ou le « Eastern Door »,
qui est un journal de Kahnawake.
Alors, pour pouvoir vous faire une bonne tête
autour de ça, n'hésitez pas à aller voir
le documentaire d'Alanis Obomsawin,
qui est d'ailleurs disponible gratuitement
sur le site de l'ONF, « 270 ans de
résistance ». Je pense que chaque Québécois
devrait voir ce documentaire-là
une fois dans sa vie.
Et surtout, n'hésitez pas à parler à des
gens qui ont été présents pendant
la crise. Merci beaucoup
Anne-Marie pour ta question,
en espérant avoir pu y répondre de manière
éclairée. N'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
des questions à Espaces autochtones.
Je vous souhaite une belle semaine.